[Applaudissements]
je me baladais sur laavenue le cœur
ouvert à l'inconnu j'avais envie de dire
bonjour à n'importe qui n'importe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui n'importe qui ce fut toi je t'ai dit
n'importe quoi il suffisait de te parler
pour ta privoisé qu'est-ce qu'il fait
qu'est-ce qu'il a qui c'est
celui-là je me présente je m'appelle
Henry il a une drôle de tête ce mec- là
je voudrais bien réussir ma vie être
aimé je n'ai besoin de personne mais
pour un flirt avec toi je ferai
n'importe quoi pour un flirt avec toi
mais non mais
non mais non mais non un chat
e je ne veux qu'elle et son amour
fragile tendre et sauvage avec ta gueule
de mes
texes de pâtre grec et tes cheveux au
0 je te
donnerai tous les bateaux tous les que
je t'aime que je t'aime que je
t'aime je t'aimee je t'aime je t'aime oh
oui je t'aime et maintenant que vais-je
faire viens à la maison il y a le
printemps qui chante allez hop tout le
monde à la
compagne allez hop le soleil nous attend
chez moi il y a des canapés où je
bercerai toutes tes poupées on
ira tu voudras quand tu
voudras prendre un
enfant femmeme oh
femme une
femme avec
toi un
enfant un enfant de toi sans être mal
marier un petit bébé dis je vudrais bien
mais je peux
point
faisons
l'amour attention Mesdames et Messieurs
dans un instant ça va
[Applaudissements]
commencer tout vous serez tous sur
le il faaip quand il roulait PASF quand
il tournait quand il marchait je ne sais
pas ce que c'était mais je crois que je
ne sauri
jamais ça s'en va et ça
revient et j'ai crié crié
oh
allô maman
bobo faut pas pleurer comme ça ce n'est
rien tu le sais bien le temps passe ce
n'est
rien
Polette
Polette tu es la reine des
papillettes notre amour ne serait pas si
beau si je n'aimais pas les
paiettes les paupiettes Devau mieux
encore que dans la chambre je t'aime
dans la cuisine rien n'est plus beau que
les mains d'une femme dans la
farine fais-moi
l'amour comme à 15 ans on a trop fait
l'amour
ensemble envie de toi moi
souvent je m'en vais voir les petites
femmes de Pigal reviens moi je t'en
supplie je t'en supplie sans toi ce
brise ma vie brise de ma
vie je suis
malade
[Applaudissements]
complètement
malade si j'avais un
marteau tu vois je suis planté planté
planté
emmène-moi à danser ce soir
dans
son
J
j contre jour dans son jour
contre jour W elle était belle belle
belle comme le jour triens je t'aime
belle belle belle comme l'amour tu ne
peux pas me laisser toute seule e la
solitude ça n'existe
pas laisse-moi t'aimer
rien qu'une nuit
e je m'en vais faire un tour du côté de
chez Swan revois mon premier amour qui
me donne est
rendez-vous je veux pas le CH je peux
pas
dire
téléphone-moi le
téléphone pleure CAPR
c'est fini
nous c'est une illusion qui Meur mais
quand l'amour s'en va et que tout est
fini pas laiss tomber tant
pis